[Musique]
je construis
munger mec
christophe chanter les marionnettes en
bérengère gilles berton elle les crée
elle travaille la mousse les plumes ou
encore le tissu à 19 ans j'ai fait mon
premier spectacle de marionnettes
complètement naïvement mais ça c'est
souvent pour l'instant autour du conte
du récit de la jeunesse au fur et à
mesure des années je me rends compte que
pour l'instant je n'ai pas vocation à
monter des textes comme hubert a pu les
monte six bérengère gilberte ont créé
autour de l'enfant hubert jappelle son
mentor travail des textes plus complexe
plus adulte c'est une oeuvre qu'hubert a
monté toute sa vie c'est à dire qu'il a
dû commencer à essayer de trouver
l'adaptation du procès de kafka même
avant 30 ans il a commencé à travailler
le texte
il a travaillé même sur des parties de
deux textes en comédien il l'a jouée en
comédien ensuite il a essayé plusieurs
fois en marionnettes
les deux artistes invitent à une balade
dans les secrets de la création
un univers que le public pourra
agrémenter de représentation et
d'ateliers